So, once again, we're
going to replace
the one remaining part of our test
that still has a standard database.
Let's actually get rid of our database.
That leaves us
with this lonely insert statement.
Once again, like with everything else,
we're going to replace that
with a content resolver call.
And of course we're actually not
going to be inserting the table.
We're going to be inserting
the content URI.
Getting rid of the nulls.
Of course this doesn't
return a location row ID.
That's alright.
We can pull it from the URI.
Using the helper function from content URI's,
we can leave that assert in there,
although it's not necessary.
And the rest of everything should
pretty much be as it always is.
We're no longer using a database at all
within test provider,
but entirely using the content provider.
Let's run our tests and see if they still work.
(silence)
And they all pass.
Congratulations, we now
have a fully functioning
content provider that can both
insert and query.
But, of course, there are other things
you might want to do
with the content provider.
Now, we're not actually going to use
any of these things in Sunshine.
But it's really important to know.
So, I suggest you
actually implement these functions.